cost of college education has gone up
1200 percent CPI 220 percent inflation
1200 how do we get to a point where
college has become a business it's no
longer like what it once was started for
yeah well College was free or nearly
free uh in California and then Ronald
Reagan came in and took that away so it
really is a matter of priorities
um I don't I think this is something
that honestly should be fully
nationalized I think we should have a
fully nationalized education system
trade school system
um I think this is one of those areas
where we've kind of experimented with
the free market and the results have
been disastrous in the same way that I
think for-profit health insurance
companies are basically just a legalized
Mafia That's in between you and your
doctor where they take their cut and
they price gouge you that's not every
industry that would fall into that
category I think there are many
Industries where
um capitalism and and competition works
out for the better for people yeah um
this is just not one of those Industries
and I think the evidence bears that out